so you definitely do not want to eat
chicken again until you watch this video
did you realize that there's or nine
billion chickens and turkeys sold every
single year and 99.9 percent of them are
factory farmed okay they're very very
cheap the other day I was in the grocery
store with my videographer and we were
looking at food and they had these fully
cooked chickens for four dollars I'm
thinking how can they afford to sell
these because the grocery store needs a
profit the distribution center needs a
profit how much do they really invest in
feeding these animals and taking care of
them now it's really interesting in 1925
it took a hundred twenty-five days to
grow and mature a chicken nowadays it
takes 47 days a month and a half to a
full adult chicken incredible now
there's a thing called CAFOs confined
animal feeding operations okay this is
part of the factory farming and I'm
going to put some links below on this
next topic but when they were testing
what's in the chicken and what's in the
feathers and the beak in the claws they
found antibiotics okay
antibiotics which were banned previously
they found antibiotics so I'm trying to
figure out how that got in there now
they found arsenic now arsenic is a
poison and arsenic makes the chicken
meat look very very pink and it also
acts as an antibiotic arsenic is highly
concentrated in the feathers the problem
is they use the feathers as a feed to
feed the chicken so it comes right back
they found residues of Benadryl
acetaminophen prozac and they basically
use these three for anxiety because
these poor chickens are so tightly
packed but the way they wake them up is
they give them caffeine okay you have to
keep them feeding to so they can grow
and also they're fed vegetarian food and
when you buy chicken sometimes it has
this label of this incredible nice
natural farm
it says natural minimally processed it
says fed vegetarian food which is really
GMO grains like corn and soy but I want
to explain
the difference between cage-free and
free-range because a lot of people have
a confusion on this cage-free means that
they're no longer in the cage and by the
way when they're in the cage it's only
basically the size of a piece of paper
that they're able to live on and that's
about it but cage free means they're
able to leave the cage go into the barn
which is about a hundred thousand
chickens in a very small space so they
don't really have that much more space
free range is basically they no longer
in the cage they're in the barn but
there's a hole and they can leave the
barn occasionally they don't really tell
you how often they can leave the barn
but there is access to leave the barn
that that's what free range means
pasture-raised means that they're
outside the barn so when you consume
chickens or eggs you want pasture raised
and organic between 1940 and 1971
millions of women were given something
called des diethylstilbestrol this is a
very powerful estrogen okay now it was
banned in 1971 because it was not only
found ineffective but it was found to be
very harmful and caused miscarriages not
only in first generation but second and
third generation but what a lot of
people don't know is the greatest usage
of this des was to livestock and it
wasn't banned until 1979 so if you were
born before 1979 chances are you were
probably exposed to DES and des really
affects the endocrine system the thyroid
the ovary the testicle the pancreas and
as a side note I want to bring up
something a little disgusting it's
called poultry litter okay that's
basically chicken feces or chicken poop
they actually use this in many different
conventional feed Lots for cattle okay
but you can't actually feed this to
chickens but you can feed it to cattle
alright guys so I'm sorry to discuss you
it probably nauseous right now and you
probably lost your appetite but just
realize there's two options okay you can
continue to buy the conventional factory
farm chicken or you can start buying
organic chicken yes it's more expensive
but this stuff comes with a package it's
much healthier to actually spend a
little bit more go to the farmers market
buy chicken that has been raised on the
land that's pasture aids that you know
it's been this chicken has been taken
care of yes it's about $20 a pound but
it's going to be much healthier for you
and it's going to be worth it in the
long run okay
so I want to know about what you think
about this video so please comment below
and tell me what you think